16-7-1 HP.
>> Brendan: BOS THE
LINE.
LEE TURNING AWAY FROM BERGE
AHEAD NOW FOR
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
CIZIKAS STUCK THAT SKATE OUT
WITH THE BLOCK.
MARTIN GIVING IT A RANGERS
TO
REILLY.
PASTRNAK FROM THE WALL.HE INTER.
SO GOOD JOB OF PENALTY KILLING .
FROM A SHARP ANGLE, IT GOESIS P.
TAYLOR HALL KNOWS HE'SND THE RE
WHEN THEY DON'T  ALL RIGHT BUT
FREDERICK A MINUTE AND A HALF.
EVERYBODY ELSE APPROACHINGT HASX
SHORTHAND GOALS
FORBORT CAN'T GET AHEAD OF HIM.
TAPS IT IN, AN OUT.
DOBSON FOLLOWS IT AHEAD.
HAT RIGHT
WING.
THAT'SE OFF THE
CORNER BOARDS ALL THE WAY HAD H
FRONT, TOO.
IT'S BEEN A GOOD PERIOD FOR THEA
GOAL LEAD AND HALL
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY.
THAT WAS A GOOD SAVE THERE BY S.
BECAUSE I SAW IT DROPPING BEHIND
THE HALL, OFF THE  1,650rendan:.
WRIST SHOT SCORES!
NOAH THAT
PASS.
>> Butch: HE KNEW HE WAS NELSON
GOT IT OUT OF THE ZONE AND
BEAUVILLIER STA A SHOT!
SAVED BY ULLMARK, FOLLOWED IT UP
AND THEY
AFTERWARDS.
THERE'S MATT BARZAL, IT DOWN.
NELSON TO THE EMPTY NET AND HE
SCORES!
CLEARING PLAYS OVER THE LAST SIX
OR SEVEN GAMES.
WATCH